نعم على كفه المستويات هذا الغضب كيف
سيعبر عن نفسه خلال الساعات المقبله هذا
السؤال اخر لكن كافه مناطق الفلسطينيه في
حاله حداد وغضب وهناك في مراكز بعض المدن
التجمهرات ودعوات لمسيرات غاضبه ايضا تهدف
للاسرى وتهتف للشهداء للشهيد خضر عدنان
بالاضافه الى ان هناك بيانات صدرت عن كافه
الفصائل والقوى والمؤسسات وكذلك السلطه
الفلسطينيه التي تنعى الشهيد وتحمل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وحكومته كامل
المسؤوليه عما تصفه بجريمه اغتياله
المتعمده وكان لافتا ايضا البيان الصادر
عن جامعه بيرزيت التي درس فيها الرياضيات
والاقتصاد وعاد اليها لدراسه الماجستير
حيث تقول في
بيانها بتصفه بابنها الشهيد وتقول بانه قد
راى في عمليات الجمع والطرح ما يتجاوز
حسابات الربح والخساره بمعناها المجرد
وحملها الى افاق ارحب وابعد فتوالي
الخسرات لا يعني الهزيمه بل تقع الهزيمه
عندما تستسلم للحظه بكل انكساراتها
وخيباتها هذا بيان جامعه بيرزيت باقي
البيانات الصادره من كافه
القوى الفلسطينيه وكذلك السلطه
تتوعد بالرد والسلطه تقول بانها ستحمل
القضيه الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
والشارع الفلسطيني والفصائل هي الاخرى
التي نعت قالت بان الحكومه الاحتلال هي من
يتحمل لكن واضح بان ذلك بات يعكس
قلقا متزايدا لدى المستويين الشعبي
والرسمي الفلسطيني على مصير باقي الاسرى
في السجون الاسرائيليه من السياسه التي
تتبعها سلطات الاحتلال والسلطات السجون
الاسرائيليه يشار في هذا السياق الا ان
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي الحالي ثمار
بن جبيل كان ومن اللحظه الاولى قد توعد
بمعاقبه وملاحقه الاسرى لدرجه انه طالب
بعدم اطعامهم الخبز الطازج وبان يقوم
بتشتيتهم واتخاذ اجراءات قمعيه واسعه ضدهم
وهناك من يرى بان استشهاد الشيخ خضر عدنان
هو نتيجه لمثل هذه السياسه اضافه الى هذا
كله منذ الاحتلال عام 67 وقعت نفذت
السلطات الاحتلال الصهي اكثر من مليون
حاله اعتقال ضد الفلسطينيين وان من بين
الفلسطينيين او الحركه الاسيره قدمت 237
شهيدا داخل السجون وكان هناك نحو 26
اضرابا عن الطعام خاضها الاسرى على مراحل
متفاوته منذ الاحتلال عدنان تحديدا كان له
خمسه اضرابات وكان قد اعتقل لنحو اثني عشر
عاما مجموع معه تم اعتقالهم معظمها كانت
اعتقالات اداريه وقد خاض فيها اربع
اضرابات عن الطعام وهذا الاخير كان الخامس
وقد استشهد في اليوم السابع والثمانين منه
وحسب المعلومات وكان في زنزانته عندما
انهار وتم نقله الى عياده السجن وهذه ليست
عياده مؤهله كما قال المحامي وانما لم يتم
نقله الى المستشفى القادر على اسعافه بعد
87 يوما من الاضراب المطبق نهائيا حاليا
كما قلنا الاراضي الفلسطينيه تشهد حاله من
الغضب اضراب شامل في كافه القطاعات ومناحي
الحياه
وتجمهرات في
مراكز المدن تحديدا
فضلا عن هذا كله على الصعيد الميداني كان
هناك ايضا هجوم مسلح استهدف ثلاثه سيارات
للمستوطنين في منطقه شمال شرق مدينه
قلقيليه في شماليه الضفه الغربيه قرب
مستوطنه اباني حفت وقالت الاساليون ان احد
احدهم قد اصيب بجراح طفيفه وان الجيش عثر
على اثار الرصاصه في
هيكل احدى هذه السيارات ويباشر عمليات
تمشيط واسعه هذا هذا هو الموقف الحالي كيف
ستتحول هذا الغضب في الساعات المقبله
سنبقى نتابع ونرسم